so tonight tonight tonight we aspire
wearily all aspired to reach higher
tonight we all aspire to dream bigger
tonight to be greater and and and this
aspiration comes from the inspiration of
tonight's honorees our Academy
colleagues who invite us through their
lives and their work to have a greater
impact we are here tonight for Owen
Royce Minh
Oh a wizard who works in light and dark
and in every genre from the documentary
style handheld camera of the French
Connection to the beautiful saturated
costumes and color and sets of Tootsie
to the to the Bluegreen rooms of the
newsroom in network and almost film noir
qualities in The Exorcist then please
consider this
none of those cherished memories from
those films required any green-screen
whatsoever we are here tonight for
Anya's Varda
a visionary with the voice a voice so
powerful and an I so experimental that
she helped to catalyze the entire French
new-wave
a pioneering director whose films and
photographs and other works of art have
invited us to consider the world in a
changing light for over 60 years and
still going strong with her new
documentary faces places we are here
tonight for Charles Burnett
director producer writer editor
cinematographer what do you have that
many hyphens you are either a film
student at USC or one of America's great
artistic voices mr. Burnett you are one
of America's great artistic voices and I
think it's important to note that his
voice is a voice that echoes outside of
the studio system
he's been on a walk uphill for a long
time and now here tonight at the
mountaintop
we are here tonight for Donald
Sutherland
omnipresent in works of excellence mash
clue ordinary people among his nearly
200 credits in Oliver Stone's JFK mr.
suburbs character is aptly named X for
time and again Donald proves the X
Factor in a career that has been vast
and varied from the Dirty Dozen to don't
look now from Animal House to the Hunger
Games he's a man of many masks and
beyond the mask for ever the voice of
gravitas and and we're also here tonight
to look into the future with a special
award for a work of virtual reality an
out-of-body experience from the inspired
mind of Alejandro Gonzalez Inarritu
I don't have a glass but let's all raise
our glasses for another toast to our
honorees to innovation and to excellence
and to tonight an evening without
competition an evening of community to
be together to be in awe and to be
inspired by these imperative artists on
behalf of the Academy I am honored to
welcome you tiry tiry thank you very
much I am very honored to be the one to
offer my congratulations to all of our
2017 honorees
[Applause]